Patrick David pointed out to me that
shooting a narrative film is you know
when you do it you you want everything
to be correct when the cameras rolling
whereas with documentaries I think
you're almost hoping that something goes
wrong so you can catch it on camera and
you brought that up to me the other day
so how is it for you when you know it's
difficult when things aren't going well
with narrative films but for you with
documentaries you're looking for those
little idiosyncrasies in someone's
speech at whatever it is how do you how
do you plan that or how do you need that
fly-on-the-wall yeah you definitely want
as much conflict as possible to come up
when you're shooting a documentary but
of course that just simply can't be
predicted or planned ever you try and
you try and focus in on subjects for
films that are sort of that sort of have
conflict inherent in them somehow like
in pursuit of silence you know I wanted
to document on silence and the natural
counterpart to that was noise and so I
sort of had this built-in kind of
protagonist antagonist kind of
relationship just right there
but yeah you can't really plan for that
kind of thing you forgot with
documentaries you kind of have to just
be rolling all the time you know and and
be paying very close attention to what's
happening in front of the camera you
know and you become very intimate with
your subject to where you kind of start
getting a sixth sense about what he's
thinking or he or she is thinking and
feeling and where the story might go and
you just kind of have to hope that you
have the intuitive sense to put the
camera in the right place when things do
turn you know a certain way you know but
it's a lot of just following your gut
and having a camera roll a lot pretty
much the whole time yeah I think I read
where you wrote that sometimes you
almost want to have no relationship
sometime when you're behind the camera
because you almost want them to not
think of you as someone to impress or
whatever it is so they might change
themselves totally yeah so you walk in
mmm I'm sorry if I'm putting words in
babe was that something you would say
yeah yeah I remember I think I read that
in the article yeah we had a especially
challenging time with ghosts we a main
character in my last two films basically
the philosopher kings and then less
Seuss and he just we just knew each
other so well like and he was so
comfortable and accustomed to having a
camera in his face that it was like us
just hanging out in the room together
every time I I was rolling and so he
would often just kind of look at me and
talk to me and tell me about his day for
example and I'd have to remind him like
I'm just shooting b-roll right now you
can I have to pretend I'm not here and
so you know once you get to know someone
- well it just becomes really hard to be
a fly on the wall you know it helps that
I think I'm not a very intimidating kind
of person you know and and so and maybe
people easily kind of drown me out and
kind of consider me part of the
background but that's helped that's
helped with the documentary filmmaking
it's they just kind of tend to drown in
tend not to notice me after a while and
you know I try and stay as quiet as
possible I try not to interact with them
at least when I'm shooting b-roll and
when I need them to be silent yeah I
just kind of keep the interaction to a
minimum well it was for us that a lot of
times we come in and people are in pitch
mode the first time you turn on the
camera they're an actor mode or whatever
and then when you come back the second
time I think you really get a better
sense of who they are yeah are there
tricks that you use because so sometimes
then you'll come back and go oh I don't
think today is the day you could just
see right if something's happened yeah
do you do things - you know I find that
the I think the key to getting those
intimate moments from your subjects is
time like you really have to invest the
proper amount of time you can't go in
thinking you're gonna get the right
b-roll in the right moments within an
hour's time you know you cannot you have
to be prepared to hang out with the guy
all day long and and and maybe you'll
capture a moment or two and a span of
eight
eight to ten hours sort of shoot you
know and I think over time they become
accustomed to you just kind of being
around and being in the background and
their guard kind of goes down and that
sort of salesman within them just kind
of naturally disappears and they become
you know you can only sort of put your
guard up for only so long you know so
time I think is the main thing is just
investing the proper time staying as
silent as possible minimizing
interaction and you know it helps if
they like you you know and respect what
you're doing respect who you are
that all helps quite a bit you know if
they feel like you're a threat obviously
they're gonna feel intimidated and it's
gonna become a problem but yeah putting
them at ease being very friendly and
complimentary and befriending them in a
very genuine way you know making them
feel like you're sort of collaborating
on a project together it definitely
helps the situation the dynamic
you